alex marlow runs breitbart news he's the
editor-in-chief he's just finished a
long
investigation into the connections
between big american media and the
communist party of china and there
are connections you'll remember that
back in 2014 michael bloomberg conceded
that in fact he does
let china the government censor
bloomberg's news
over the past year there's been
questions about the journalism
going on in china and whether the
company in its effort to grow
has muzzled
in china they have rules about what you
can publish
we follow those rules if you don't
follow the rules you're
not in the country we write the stories
that we think are interesting
and we distribute them where they are
allowed to be distributed
we follow the rules well it turns out
the rest of us should have followed up
on that alex marlow did
he found that bloomberg executives
regularly flew to china to meet with
senior officials in the chinese
communist party
those would include that country's
deputy propaganda minister you can read
the details of all of this in his new
book called breaking the news exposing
the establishment media's
hidden deals and secret corruption alex
marlow we're happy to say joins us
tonight alex thanks so much
for coming on this is one of those
stories that i think all of us remember
at the back of our heads without
whatever happened to that
you found out this is book length but
in the next three minutes just outline
what you found about these connections
sure tucker i'm thrilled to share some
of the details of my bombshell
investigation into corporate media and
this
isn't just a book about simple liberal
bias if you're watching a show like this
or reading breitbart you know it goes so
much deeper than that this is about
weaponized corporate media against the
individual and how deep their ties are
to some of the worst entities in the
world including the chinese
propagandists now
there's this group called the scio the
southern central information
office i'm sorry the china's information
state
state council information office
apologize for that and they control the
licensure
into whether or not bloomberg has access
to the gigantic market of china for
their bloomberg lp
business but it's also known as the
state's propaganda office and so what
they've done
is they've sent deputies including a guy
named kevin
sheeky kevin sheeky went on to become
the campaign manager for michael
bloomberg and he went multiple times
bloomberg himself went in 2015 and they
would have these meetings with these
chinese propagandists
and the design i believe is to extend
the licensure which is up for renewal
every 24 months so what we saw with the
conversations
according to the scio propagandis they
all
involved a couple of themes and these
themes are developing
chinese media relationships with the
united states media companies
and presenting china and chinese stories
to the world
i don't know if this is still going on
but shiki comes in
he's the vice president of bloomberg he
goes into bloomberg's campaign
now he's back at bloomberg but he's not
alone this goes throughout the company
and it continues as far as we know
and is not limited to bloomberg
what's so distressing about this is most
of our audience i would imagine doesn't
watch bloomberg but if you work on wall
street
you definitely do you've got bloomberg
software on your desk i mean
people are using bloomberg news to
understand
world financial markets and so
propaganda has filtered through
bloomberg has a massive effect on our
country
that's correct and it's also
representative of what i believe
is a media establishment in the united
states of america
that is willing to compromise on basic
american values bloomberg ran for
president of the united states he's
currently the u.s
envoy to the u.n on climate he's excused
chinese abuse of the environment and
pollution
he's also excused the fact that xi
jinping who's a dictator he said he's
not a dictator
he's willing to do a lot of work with a
regime that does not have a first
amendment
yet he wanted to be president he's a
huge democrat mega donor tucker but
perhaps most importantly
he's one of the biggest employers of
journalists
on the planet as we know it and this
type of guy is willing to
work with chinese propagandists who do
not believe in free speech
so loathsome so loathsome but a
billionaire so he gets a pass alex
marlow i appreciate your coming on
tonight
congratulations on the book and thank
you for your reporting
thanks tucker hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else